the most common question I get asked is
hey Michael what's your favorite fact
and I never know how to answer that I
like a lot of facts and my favorite
changes minute to minute but if you've
ever met me and asked me I probably told
you my usual answer
we don't know how many people there are
human population estimates are educated
guesses arrived at by very smart people
using many different sources but we're
pretty sure they're off by about two to
three percent that means there are one
to three hundred million humans on this
planet who may or may not exist every
single one of us is so important to the
universe but yet collectively we're just
like all the spiders on Earth how many
are there
I think it's easy to think that we know
a lot more than we know to think that
everything is accounted for and
accountable but in reality we are all
just a bunch of soft animals walking in
and out of rooms
[Music]